miles de hectáreas consumidas por las
llamas guardabosques y trabajadores de
la agricultura trabajan a contrarreloj
para frenar el fuego el terreno es
amplio O sea no estamos hablando de que
hay un foco y que usted está trabajando
sobre un foco no el terreno que ocupa el
incendio es amplio en condiciones muy
adversas Loma
situaciones bien complejas las llamas
han alcanzado el parque nacional mensura
piloto una de las zonas más biodiversas
del país aunque las autoridades apuntan
a la fuerte sequía que atraviesa la isla
aún investigan las causas del siniestro
mismo hecho de que el incendio haya
consumido hectáreas dentro del área
protegida es un elemento bastante
desastroso del punto de vista ecológico
Aún es muy difícil hacerse un estimado
de todas formas tiene la misión que una
vez que se declare ha pagado el fuego es
decir la fase de recuperación hacer una
evaluación de impacto de daños de
impacto de forma preliminar y luego
haremos una evaluación mucho más amplia
en 35 días de El impacto que ha tenido
en la biodiversidad dentro de esta área
protegida otra conflagración en el
municipio de consolación del sur fue
declarada este lunes bajo control Pese a
que aún tiene algunos fuegos activos en
2022 en Cuba se presentaron 284
incendios de los cuales el 90% fueron
provocados entre las principales
acciones que los motivaron se encuentran
que más no autorizadas la utilización de
vehículos en sistemas integrados para
evitar chispas y la casa furtiva para el
año en curso se prevé que existan entre
320 y 445 incendios antes de que termine
el período seco en mayo